this week i'll have two more lines in
order to focus on the next project
that's why i wanna focus on the earth
design and how they should be built
first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
SFL this is important what you care
about the order in the sea they're bored
I care about the order however in the
recipe box well not so much your girl
isn't so important and when it comes to
the recipes however was important is how
they finally look how they taste that's
why that I would go for great and in
reader board I would go for analyst
[Music]
I the little bark dust is to build a
list of stoppable a user must be able to
toggle between the leaders depending on
the time period whether it's all time or
whether it's just on in the last 30 days
in order to toggle I would use the towel
and I still wondering whether to keep
the place number to the right if you put
the number on the left still from the
design perspective the avatar which is
the face will bring the fast attention
so maybe you really better to keep the
mother first and so to the labs because
people will read like an aspirin or less
in the lists so they read in the line
later they go down they got another line
so at the end of each line they will see
the number like 1 2 3 4 maiden we better
I will prepare some varieties because of
the fact that it is the free codes
cardboard I will use their color their
greenish color
and this will be my main theme car and
the cedar boards design general I would
like to keep it clean hand as well as
possible because it gives the impression
of space especially if you have a less
that's really homogeneous and their
items repeat each item on the list would
have to be a link so we have to be
clickable I want to make it as
interactive as possible so I want to
redirect the users whenever they click
any reader whatever they touch any
leader on the list and then whatever
they wrecked them to this leaders who
are chosen to today our free code camp
account this is the first version of the
design of free code camp leaders pores
and the app should allow for toggling
between leaderboards according to the
time span so by default i will have
played less 30 days and a user can also
go to all-time leaders where the total
points will be highlighted on the right
there's additional information which is
the number on the list so I was
wondering whether to put them to the
left this is just a prototype I want to
make the whole item here the whole line
clickable and redirecting to a given
user so whenever I click some James here
in this line with whether it would be an
avatar or at the line here I want to
make this whole area clickable so to me
this whole area the whole line flickable
for a user to be redirected to Twitter
director to free codes camp user's
profile and this way this app should be
more more interactive because then they
can go to this Twitter gets home
linkedin they can see their activity
right
I have its line on mobile horizontally
vertically and also on tablet screens as
well as on desktop I was considering the
option of putting two columns on the
wider screen such as some tablets or on
the desktop however I'm calling patterns
of a list is like from top to bottom and
the numbers should go from one to this
one hundred down therefore I decided to
keep one column but Center it and simply
make it very similar on all devices
Jerry what changes on iPads tablets and
desktops is that I keep two lines with
the information next to the avatar not
free as on mobile phones vertically this
is the first draft and let's start with
it later we will see what happens during
their codes implementation
[Music]
I love iterating over the projects and
this is what I did with this one with
free code come leaderboard because the
first design like these numbers on the
right well finally I decided that they
are important enough to be kept but not
to be big as the avatars that's why I
kept them smooth as small as you see
here so i will put the relative
positional a layer absolutely to work
and i will put the numbers to the left
corner of the avatars so this way the
position in the leaderboard would be
pretty visible but not more important
than the faces than the avatars of the
people and what I did also in this red
design is that i will put that if it's
like last 30 days so the last 30 days
points will be here to the right this
way it's writing and you can reach
better result I believe that's better
solution by added the italic style to
the points that aren't the most
important in a given top so if we are in
the last 30 days the total points so the
points from all time they're in italics
the reason for that is to still keep
them and buts to diminish their
importance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's friday i start today with looking
for the inspiration so i'm looking for
inspiration for the design and looking
how other people do the friend could
boobs some recipe apps and i started
with coca and looking whether there are
kako campers did in the final coat I
don't want to use bootstrap again
because it's a pretty simple thing to do
I will try to practice my flexbox skills
once again and it will be more
challenging for sure but the more much
more fun I want to not just me my first
but this time I also have a look maybe
at this offline first I'm also found of
cooking and you know I'm really a foodie
this is also one of the reasons i live
here in spain right now but that's why
this project seems awesome more exciting
than the rest and i ran the food book so
i keep my recipes also online I don't
have a lot of time right now to do it
but I love culinary for the racket
that's why this project is pretty fun
for me so let's get back to work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the design of the recipe box
this time I focus mostly just on your
mobile because the wire screens will be
pretty similar so I focused on the
material design here on the cards and on
the specs additional specs that I built
so in mm experience design i also added
the user stories that this project will
have to meet and there is our stars come
from freaked out kind of course i tried
to define the user and the technology
but also the extra stuff that can be
done about this app probably in the
first situation and i will just
introduce some some of them and then
let's go to the design i want to make it
in a grid system this will be the home
screen with that with the index so the
recipes should be visible as you see
them alphabetically they should be
distributed this way so we have Brad
chocolate cinnamon rolls crumble
whenever you click them whenever you
click the recipe you go to the day of
you when you scroll you go to the bottom
of it so you have the ingredients you
have instructions and later you can edit
it or you can delete it and when you
edit it you will go to to the Edit view
you can also delete the recipe and there
will be Russians for user if they really
want to delete it or not mmm if they
click delete they will delete it from
the list it was here so crumbles here
after cinnamon rolls but right now it's
deleted because I am they didn't from
I hope you they will be able to add the
new recipe and save it so on the false
and horizontally I want to do one more
column and on tablets I want to add one
extra color which will be also captain
desktops but here and I wanna remove the
fab um to the top that's why I also
change the color to differentiate this
fat from them rest also designed the
homescreen empty state so I'm not sure
about I'm not sure about this text yet
but whenever there's no recipe there
should be some hair for user to to use
the bottom line to do something maybe
I'll have some some nice picture here um
plus the text to make it more juicy next
week I'm going to start one of this
project probably it will be the leader
board keep on doing and see you next
week and pitching because there will be
a big news coming to this channel really
soon
[Music]